okay why did we go ahead and get started
for that yeah so uh thank you offer and
Steve's master's thesis defense so the
program yesterday even though the book
says that Steve has his master's degree
he acts II won't have this and then
submits is right up which I'm confident
he'll do in glowing manner because we've
already signed it behind the faculty him
ohsu in d'box anyway so so anyways he
received his MD from Brown University in
Providence Rhode Island chief resident I
remember getting an email from Tom
Cooney telling me about this great
candidate for our fellowship program
about two and a half years ago I think
that turned out to be the case and he's
uh he's done the master's degree and is
defending his master's thesis today on
the topic of support he's also for the
role I assume he'll continue in some
capacity with the clinical decision
support committee in the hospital so as
always Steve will give this presentation
will have a public presentation but
public can ask questions we'll all be
dismissed leaving behind this committee
that may ask further questions then he
leaves in his committee decides whether
if he does then he still needs to finish
his write up a good way to student okay
thanks so much dr. Hirsch I appreciate
that introduction thanks everybody for
coming down and here we might talk today
I got a few as many of you know I'm
fairly close with alfredo Elmyra Susan
former postdoc here he sent me you know
the whole flurry of messages through
what that no I got goes to something
funny he got showing these funny videos
in all these videos you showed I just
thought oh my god I'd be so embarrassed
to show maybe that'll be the funny
things just talking about so um the time
of my Cossacks political decision
support malfunctions and obviously we'll
sort of talk about definitions quite a
bit but I thought hope it was helpful up
front to just sort of explained clinical
decision support what it is it
malfunctions what those are so clinical
decision support is really about giving
information and knowledge at the point
of care to help improve outcomes and
malfunctions I'm going to sort of
loosely defined at this point it's just
sort of errors or when the system breaks
so a little roadmap about what we'll
talk about we'll talk about clinical
decision support some of the background
work that's been done on it some work on
anomaly detection and malfunctions and
then also talked about clinical students
for malfunctions which is that but me of
what I'm going to talk about today so
what's the what's the motivation for
this work and it's really that a lot of
the clinical decision support tool that
we have they can break and we don't
really have a method or a framework to
detect them so the example I'm going to
show here has to do with a friend so
heparins of blood thinning medication
that's you fairly commonly in the
hospital is used for deep vein
thrombosis myocardial infarction a
number of other things has a fairly
narrow therapeutic window meaning too
much of the medication you can get a
life-threatening bleeding event or too
little it doesn't work so it's really
important that when heparins being used
that there's associated orders to
monitor it in place at all those orders
sort of tell the nurse how to titrate it
and they also dictate how often lab
should be drawn so what I'm shown right
here is a figure from how often a
clinical decision support alert fire is
related to to use of heparin so the way
that this alert is set up it basically
looks and if a patient has orders for
heparin it checks to see that they have
these associated quarters to do the
monitoring and a safety
if it doesn't feel earth fires so just
real briefly to explain this figure and
this will actually be sort of an example
many of the figures that will show their
all-time series so often though this one
in particular sort of buckets months at
the bottom and then alert firing rate is
the number of times the solar fire month
you can see when the alert came online
febuary was going about 150 or so and
then sort of even at around 250-300 and
then it dropped off so why did that
happen currently we don't really have a
good framework to understand that or
even a system to detect that is that
something that should have happened was
there a change in the workflow did
something changing the way that heparin
is ordered when it's administered and we
just don't really know so that's sort of
what what sort of the motivation for the
work and at this point I'm just to sort
of get a little bit as the definitions I
would call this an anomaly so this this
heparin alert it's not functioning as we
expected or in as expected or consistent
with its past historical pattern I can't
say it's a malfunction I don't know if
it's broken yet or not so we'll talk
about that a little bit more so what
about clinical decision support so as I
said before it's really about giving
sort of knowledge and information that's
person-specific filtered at at the point
of care to help improve outcomes there's
a number of different frameworks for
this is my personal favorite one called
the five rights that was developed by
Jerry ash are off and some other
colleagues so the first piece of the
five rights is the right information so
you want it to be evidence-based you
want to important pertinent actionable
you want it to the right person okay so
oftentimes in a sort of physician
centric world growth ain't no it needs
to go to the initiative position but in
other situations that may actually be
best ordered to the patient maybe
someone else on the care team and what's
the format a lot of what we're going to
talk about today relates to alerts but
there's a lot about a clinical decision
support out there disorder said its flow
sheets data visualization and what about
the channel today's talk will focus on
the electronic health record but
sometimes maybe through mobile devices
do patient portal or you know Derek say
it sometimes on paper might even be the
right thing and then we also want to
have it at the right point in the
workflow so if you're thinking about
something related to some medication
interaction you probably want to have
that as
extreme in the workflow at least at the
point of ordering or at the point that
someone's thinking about Orion not at
the point of myth you know a bar code
administration or something like that
the political of Student Support has a
fairly long history it's sort of seminal
paper was back in nineteen seventy five
was a paper that clan MacDonald put
together where he they had a system
where they basically took for about
maybe 50 different sort of care
scenarios and when those came up looked
through the patient's record and
provided recommendations to the
providers and what they found in a
crossover RCT was actually that
providing that information to the
providers improved the process related
outcomes that they were looking at so a
lot of lot of clinical student support
Charleston done says there have been a
number of different systematic reviews
the first one by kawamoto was mostly
confined to academic centers using
homegrown systems we look at this
process outcomes and didn't find
anything more than that what of what did
improve those brats outcomes a couple of
features that were associated with
clinical support systems that worked and
this is what sort of feeds into the the
five rights framework that I talked
about before having it be at the right
point in the clinical workflow having it
be associated with the time and location
of the decision making using
recommendations and also having it be
computerized the next system atrophy
really show the same things again
process outcomes mostly internal systems
that were developed in academic settings
then in 2011 finally there was some some
data outside the academic settings and
in commercial systems and found that
they were able to improve some clinical
process outcomes and the most recent one
from 2014 looked at just RCTs related to
clinical decision support and they
looked at mortality morbidity and some
economic outcome founders no effect on
mortality there was a there wasn't a
statistically significant effect on
morbidity but no effect on economic
outcomes and that included commercial
systems primarily so clinical decision
support has a lot of different forms
this work the taxonomy that I'm going to
sort of talk about was actually one that
was developed by dr. Adam
I who is the first PhD graduate from the
program so the first part of it is
medication dosing support so you that
could take a number of different forms
but if medications dose needs to be
dosed based on weight based on age
kidney disease adjusted for liver
dysfunction anything like that maximum
daily doses those things could be
implemented into a system and just to
sort of give that a little bit of a
story there's a case report as recently
as 2011 for a six month old that had a
fever and a cough and was brought to the
emergency room the patient was diagnosed
with pneumonia given as if throw meissen
which is a reasonable medication and be
given patient received 500 milligrams
which is a average adult sized oats
about a hundred child needed the sit the
hospital where the patient was seen
didn't have any clinical decision
support in place patient got the 500
milligrams ended up having a cardiac
arrest and unfortunately died and that's
something that people feel like
generally you know could be could be
prevented through clinical decision
support other systems or other parts of
the framework order facilitators are
fairly common I know that's our artists
t those are most commonly seen as order
sets so oftentimes for a lot of
different diagnoses in the hospital
there's a fairly routine set of orders
that the patient will get with some you
know with some wiggle room for dosing
and things and this the ideal with this
is you want to have the orders that are
set up so people can just pick the
things off it that they commonly do and
don't miss the one that's that they need
information display is another one this
is demonstrating showing the pricing of
various lab tests and how that would
inform decision-making and then expert
systems this is just a cartoon the
patient's sitting there with a doctor if
you can't read the bottom it says if you
want a second opinion all I ask my
computer there's a number of different
antibiotic support ventilation
management diagnostic tools prosti tools
that fall into that that category the
final two pieces of atoms framework the
top one is about workflow support so
that's about order routing registry
functions medication reconciliations the
figure that i'm showing you up here is
from twinrix which is a which is from a
group at the university of maryland so
they've focused on creating this this
workflow support tool for med
and reconciliation medication
reconciliation is the act of sort of
looking at the different lists of
medications that the patients taking at
a certain point in time trying to find
out what they're actually taking what
they should be taking and then have them
try to be taking what you want and the
idea what this is this is for you know
transition period in the hospital so you
have intake ebooks are you take unique
which is what they were taking us unique
on the way in it takes similar similar
medications at the hospital medication
are identical and then unique in the
hospital the idea is sort of try to
bring all that into together so you
appropriately discharge them on the
medications and the last part of the
framework is alerts and reminders and
these are can be fairly broad but
essentially doing about the idea of
combining me either medication
medication medication condition
condition condition physician attribute
and conditions a whole host of different
things and they're pretty flexible and
they're sort of presented either as
oftentimes us or intrusive sometimes pop
ups within the workflow and that's sort
of what we'll focus on today however
clinicals didn't support the studies
that I talked about they always sort of
examined clinical decision support in
isolation not in the totality of the
whole system and it's a much more
complicated thing in real world settings
most places have a pretty high volume of
alerts a lot of people feel like those
alerts are not often times probably or
have more false positives and there may
be a little bit more meaningless than
they like and there's this phenomenon of
alert fatigue which I'm sure many of you
are familiar with so a lot of the
settings that people have looked at
alert fatigue it's mostly related to
drug drug interactions but almost 50 in
some sense 50 and as high as ninety six
percent of those alerts are overridden
and often times there's very little
effort made to prioritize the alerts
meaningless ones are really shown right
alongside ones that could be
life-threatening or critical so sort of
as the background of the work that that
I undertook it's you know thinking that
it's really important that the clinical
decision support that we do put out
there needs to be high quality we need
to make sure that we monitor it and
understand what it's doing because if we
just sort of push it out of the nest and
let it fly and have no idea what it's
good doing it's really going to
contribute to this this unfortunate
consequence that is alert fatigue so
knowledge management surrounding clinic
decision support has always been a very
resource intensive activity so this is
one of my favorite figures that I ever
saw in a journal so it's from the
British Medical Journal in 1998 so what
the authors of this study did is they
went around to maybe about 60 primary
care practices and said we want to have
every give us every guideline that
you're supposed to be implementing and
what they did is that they stacked it up
there was 850 511 it was you know some
semi sand meters high weigh about 30
kilograms and you could imagine how
astronomical that's grown and some work
that dr. ashe's done in our department
showed that it'll keep them current on
the content for clinical decision
support is really one of the major
drivers for some of the unintended
consequences of CD s and when I think
about you know the knowledge management
piece and sort of managing CD s I sort
of think about it as three parts the
first is you know making sure the
contents valid so if it's something
that's guideline-based you know do you
have the most up-to-date guidelines are
the guidelines actually you know are
they are they valid and then the next
piece is sort of technical validity is
the CDF doing what you want it and
that's really where the focus of my
studies going to come in today so is it
performing as intended and then efficacy
is sort of the Holy Grail is actually
doing what we want if we're giving
clinical decision support so people stop
ordering so much blood are they actually
not worry as much pleasure as we're
walking to or are they ordering as much
blood as we wanting to so most of the
clinical decision support that that we
sort of manage here at ohsu is what i
would call rule-based so that has a
trigger so there's some event within the
electronic health record that says okay
we're going to now trigger this event
and we're going to go look through and
see if this patient and their criteria
sort of matched his clinical decision
support rule and then the input data
elements can be anything from you know
actually to the patient the diagnosis
the time of day the setting anything you
could really think of and then the
intervention in this case is going to be
you know an alert and then offer choices
can be any host number of things and
really you could think about these type
of rule based ones is really kind of
simple or in some cases complex if-then
statements so if you have condition a
and condition be or if you have
condition a and
medication a then show alert X but one
of the just to sort of flesh this out a
little bit more i'm going to show you
one alert that i've actually done a
little bit of work on outside of this
state so this is an alert related to
overuse of red blood cell transfusions
so for those that aren't familiar with
it we've been really marching back on
how much red blood cells we transfused
the patients we used to try to just
transfuse him till we can get the
numbers high as possible and found out
that we were probably doing a lot more
harm than good with that so it really
kind of march back on that so most of
the guidelines say really if patients
aren't symptomatic that you probably
shouldn't transfuse them for amenia
until their hemoglobin is less than
seven or in this case of equivalent of
medicare to 20 21 so with this the way
that this one works is we go ahead and
when there's an order for red blood
cells there that's placed in the system
this rules n triggered it looks at the
patient's most recent hematocrit and
some attributes related to the patient
because it doesn't apply to all patients
we're just using on impatience some of
the impatience are excluded if they meet
the criteria that we want we go ahead
and we present this alert and then at
the bottom which you can see is with
those buttons at the bottom sort of
provides in different reasons that they
may override the alert if they feel it's
not appropriate to follow that
recommendation so when you have a
clinical decision support rule like this
you might can think that there's a
number of different ways in which the
whole could actually break down so this
system when we go ahead and build it we
you know we use hematocrit and we use
the code from a mattock root and we sort
of burn it into the clinical decision
support system but there is the
possibility that the lab who ultimately
controls the way that hematocrit done
and studied may choose to do it through
a different way and they have all the
sudden they're implementing it through a
different mechanism and then that
doesn't get past that to us at all of a
sudden all the hematocrit that are being
done the hospital are using a different
lab coat and that's one way there could
also be attributes about the patients
that are somehow different of the
patients being described differently
other providers being described
differently within the EHR as the
workflow drastically changed in some way
that we didn't capture weren't aware of
it the decision support could just
malfunction so I want to talk a little
bit about so
or the amount of work that's been done
on clinical decision support
malfunctions so far so this is work from
Adam Wright who I mentioned developed a
CD s framework and as a PhD graduate
from here so about a month and a half
ago they published a 4 case series of
clinical decision support malfunctions
so they looked at clinical decision
support malfunctions from their
homegrown EHR which they just recently
transitioned offer then I started with
an alert cohort of about 200 or so so
the figure that i'm going to show you
here is related to pediatric LED screens
so probably we didn't know something
about pediatric LED screen made recently
learned about it with everything to
happen in Flint Michigan it is now
happening in Portland but essentially
lettuce and neurotoxins particularly the
damaging a developmental stage of life
so there's Universal screaming
guidelines that children engage to 35
should be screened for let so this
clinical decision support rule that they
had in the outpatient setting basically
would look at a patient if they were
over 2 and did have a recent LED screen
it would send an alert to provide an
efficient do this care for the patient
so in this figure what you see across
the x-axis is the date and the y-axis is
the number of firings per day the light
blue I think that's like blue in color
black and black appreciate a flag to a
colorblind like blues weekdays Black is
weekends so what you see basically is
until you know when the alert was fired
it was going about maybe 22 almost 400
times a day and then basically in 2009
just dropped off I didn't have any
activity until late 2011 when they went
back through and try to figure out what
actually happened they looked through
the alert itself and someone had gone
back in or the an analyst had gone back
in and added two additional clauses to
the to the rule so the rule now when the
after the analyst divison the rule
looked to see what the patient's smoking
status was and the patient's gender now
even if you could concede that you
should be asking to go for their smoking
status was insensitive America
when when it was done no one the the
clause is what the answer should be
would never put in there right so it
just said evaluate smoking status but it
didn't have a yes no for it and so it
always the rule by default when that
happens in their system always defaulted
it fall so best they could tell someone
went in started editing this rule maybe
realize they weren't supposed to be
doing it was in the wrong rule but never
went back and faced it the four other
the three additional CVS malfunction
that they identified one was what I
talked about as a possible before which
is a change in the lab coat related to
thyroid stimulating hormone they also
found a sort of general system-wide
software update that they perform that
caused a massive increase in the number
of alerts that were happening and that
was caught very quickly and then the
fourth was related to third party
content so most healthcare systems use
third party vendors to provide the
medication information and they had an
error related to that but within the
commercial within the commercial vendor
EHR sphere no one's really looked at
this yet so the data that I'll present
will be some of the first stuff that's
been done and there within the
commercial electronic health records
there really isn't much of a mechanism
to monitor the clinical decision support
and we really don't have much of a
framework to really detect it and that's
really the focus of what I'm going to
sort of hopefully in part on you today
that I did so moving a little bit into
the method so anomaly detection which is
one of the underlying methods that I'm
going to use in here so use it a lot of
different fields credit card for asking
for our computer security industrial
processes na mele you know a lot of
different names outliers exceptions
oddities surprises and they all talk
about sort of you know trying to find
patterns in the data that we didn't
expect or didn't conform to prior
behavior it's a little bit different
most of us probably familiar with sort
of statistical outlier detection where
you basically want to find the data that
doesn't make sense and just get rid of
it but the idea what the nominally
detection is the data that doesn't make
sense or doesn't conform to prior
patterns represent something you
represent some real world event that you
hope in some ways actionable an anomaly
detection I sort of think about you know
it doesn't have any judgment on it's
just saying you know this doesn't
conform to what you'd expect whereas
malfunction which is a term i'm going to
use is really talking about you know it
is this rule or whatever it is doesn't
design as you design doesn't function as
you designed or expected I a it's not
working so visualization is kind of one
of the primary methods of anomaly
detection so the example i'm going to
show you here is related to influenza
like illness so influenza like illness
is exactly what the word is say which
basically is when you have someone who
has an illness that looks like Hansel
and so the CDC uses this not quite a
diagnosis but this sort of
categorization to help inform their
influence allotment for the year in
outbreaks so I've just sort of created
some fake data here but hopefully
curious graph so on the x-axis months
and six months increments and then on
the why you have the number of ili cases
recorded so what you see it and again
the data is made up so try to just
imagine how beautiful it is so there's a
spike in the wintertime and then it sort
of drops off in the summer and the spike
in the winter time goes up to about 20
cases this single point that I
highlighted is eating case of influenza
like illness now that in the data set
it's not necessarily abnormal but in the
context of it happening during the
summer is clearly abnormal as a
contextual anomaly and the idea is feel
the the data you know you put it in a
form when you visualize it to help the
expert user sort of go through it and
make that assessment but the data itself
isn't actually all that informative
without the visualization another method
is statistical process control is
particularly useful for time series data
statistical process control requires
that the outcome of interest is sort of
in a steady state or has some level of
some level of variability that that you
can manage so what is happening here so
this is a figure where I create a system
or process control chart so this is an
alert related
who patience and what their HMO is so
you can see it fires approximate you
know anywhere from thirty seventy times
a month so with this disco process
control chart what you essentially do is
you create an average line and aggregate
over what you're looking at and then you
can create a perfect role of a sort of
lower control limits and you can adjust
those controllers to pay upon house you
know sensitive you want your test to be
or how specific in this case these are
three times standard deviation and then
there's a number of different formal
pests that you can use to say when it's
sort of out of bounds of what you'd
expect but the objectives for the
research that I undertook were firstly
to determine whether there were CES
malfunctions occurring in commercial EHR
secondly characterize the pathways that
we're leading to those malfunctions if I
found them and then describe methods of
detection and prevention for those
malfunctions um so the methods that I
used so the Lord cohort came from ohsu
which is a 500 students expect tertiary
care facility the electronic health
record we're using here is epic in the
electronic health record here the alerts
are known as best practice advisories
not all best practice advisories sort of
our alerts there's some other processes
that we use them for but minor can find
two alerts as I described them
previously all the all the alerts that I
examine here under local knowledge
management implementation so this none
of this is third party content that we
purchased this is all things that we as
an institution decided implemented in a
responsible for managing the alert
cohorts from five years in twenty ten to
twenty fifteen and I restricted the
cohort to activate an invisible folders
the primary outcome that I looked at
with the number of malfunctions and
unclassified anomalies / alert month an
alert month is essentially the number of
months that alerts were active so if you
only had two alerts one was active three
months one was actu'ly five months you
have eight alert ones we have a few more
than that though is for the data
abstraction and refinement process so
for those of you that don't know in the
EHR the production database isn't really
usable for any sort of analytics because
of its hierarchical structure so it
undergo
strack transform and load and gets put
into a relational tables I wrote sequel
queries to those relational tables to
create the data set and then did some
refinement work with in stata to get the
final data set the visualization
essentially what I did is I created data
visualizations for all the alerts within
the cohort I applied my knowledge
regarding clinical decision support as
well as the specific clinical domains
that were there and they categorize the
alert fireman history as either
anomalous or not again anomaly different
than malfunction anomaly doesn't conform
to historical patterns or expected
malfunction not working as intended and
to make this a little bit clearer to
make the visual visual I'll just take
you through two of them so this is an
alert related to patients with diabetes
me a1c so patients did not have anyone
see within the last six months there the
provider who is seen in an ambulatory
setting would get an alert so this is
again a time series plot this is monthly
to make it easier to visualize the
number of alerts on the y-axis so did
you see that starts maybe about 1600 and
then goes up over time to about 2000 or
so you know there's a slight difference
there but that likely is increasing
likely as the result of sort of
increased number of visits so I did not
call something like this and anomaly in
comparison this is an alert we'll talk
about it in depth little bit more belen
to a medication an ox of Paran that's
fairly similar to happen a little bit
different this alert doesn't quite fire
as much but you see when it started when
about 30 40 50 times month there's a
little bit of a spike and then drop down
to single digits and it continued in
that place for another until I found it
basically and this was considered an
anomaly so yes or normally on this one
following that once I had the visual
anomalies I went through and I validated
them so the validation part was to
define whether they were malfunctions
their CD s was not working as designer
intended whether it was a false positive
amelie and the false positive anomaly
its anomalous meaning that
it's not conforming to historical
patterns expected but it's not actually
broken something that we intentionally
changed either within the CBS world or a
workflow change there's something to
explain it that it's actually the CES is
still doing exactly what we wanted and
then a third category which is
unclassified anomaly so that's sort of
the unfortunate bucket that things get
put into when through the validation
process I wasn't able to sort of
determine what it was and what the
validation process sort of looked like
is you know I would start with the CD s
roll look at it there's some timestamp
data on there as far as what got changed
when speak with the analysts in some
cases the analysts are still employed at
ohsu we have some change management logs
that we keep for the CD s as well as
when there's changes with an epic as a
whole and I had access to all those that
speak with the clinical owners so if it
was an alert related psychiatry I'd
speak with both the psychiatry at big
analysts and speak with the psychiatry
folks who sort of wanted that piece of
CD has implemented and then as needed if
it involved pharmacy or laboratory at
speak with those those respective
informatics folks as well for
statistical process control that was
applied to a subset of the alert cohort
when appropriate so as I mentioned for
to use statistical process control it
needs to be sort of in a steady state
meaning you need to have a reasonable
level of variability to it to be able to
apply it so not all the alerts was that
applicable to and we'll talk about that
a little bit and I used count charts and
that required an assumption of stable
denominators which is probably
reasonable if your denominators aren't
changing one in 20 months twenty percent
the tests that I apply when using
statistical process control so a single
point outside three standard deviations
control limit line two out of three
points greater than two standard
deviations above the average line and
both those points on the same side eight
or more points on it one side of the
average line or six or more points
steadily increasing or decreasing once I
completed this statistical process
control anomaly detection method I then
the performance characteristics of it so
as many of you know accuracy alone isn't
really a sufficient classifier when
you're looking at things that are
anomalous or rare because you can just
say everything's normal and then you can
be 99.9 and so to do this I calculated
the sensitivity the positive predictive
value in the F measure there is no gold
standard for the data set that I have so
what I essentially did is I took
statistical process control use that to
categorize the subset as I are anomalous
or not and then i used the visualization
classification as the gold standard for
that the idea or the possibility of
validating the entire cohort was was is
pretty much resource prohibitive because
the amount of time it takes and and the
ability to actually do it so jumping
into the results so there was 226 active
invisible alerts that I examine that
representative told 8300 alert months
subsequently applying visual anomaly
detection there was 21 visual anomalies
four of those were classified as an
options nine were unclassified eight or
false positives the so I'm going to walk
through the four malfunction so I think
these these are sort of important to
spend some time on so the first
malfunctions related to an ox apparent
knocks the parents of medication similar
to heparin it's used for deep vein
thrombosis myocardial infarction
essentially as a blood thinner like
Hepburn requires ancillary orders or
accompanying orders to make sure that
it's appropriately dost and monitored so
what happened with when this alert was
created it looked through the system to
see that patients were on heparin they
had the appropriate medication the
appropriate ancillary orders done so in
this figure what you see when kneeler
started it was fire about 40 to 60 times
a month increased a little bit and
eventually dropped down to single digits
so when I talked with the pharmacy
informatics folks as soon as I brought
this to their attention they said you
know actually this is kind of an error
that we created so what actually happens
is we're done with the knocks apparent
the way they deal with some of the stuff
that they create alerts around they
actually create dummy medication records
so when I
physician go into the system and I go
into the order entry screen into the
formulary and I search for an ox
apparent it's actually a double order
that's the one that's tied to the CD s
the real order for the medication is
sort of hidden in the background what
actually happened was they were doing
some routine maintenance on the hospital
formulary lists the real medication
record got sort of slipped back on to
the in the physician order area and it
wasn't intended to this malfunction
found it with visible visualization and
statistical process control the next
malfunctions related to influenza so
this is a little bit hard to see on this
but I'll try to sort of cute into so
this alert basically what it does is we
found influenza vaccinations super
important can help reduce morbidity
mortality in a number of different
groups and is that often times of
quality measure for a lot of hospital
systems so which if you you know
participates in a lot of those quality
measure reported and found that they
were actually going to drive with 0
during influenza but actually
administering in the hospital setting
turn out to be more problematic what was
happening was a lot of issues before the
immunization is actually given so they
created an alert that would display to
the nurse so for patients who had an
active order for influenza vaccination
and then subsequently had an order for
discharge on alert was provided to the
nurses and hey this patient needs to
have this influenza vaccine given before
discharge so what you see um basically
when the alert gets turned on them
because we activated and deactivated
each year it went off about a hundred
times a month and then sort of drops
down at the influenza season Wayne's
there's nothing for the 2011-2012
influenza season and then it comes back
on for 2012-2013 and 2013-14 and then
it's gone for a 14 and 15 and actually
going back and speaking with the
analysts what actually happened was
there's a our CD s analyst who does most
of this is responsible for sort of
reactivating as each year she was
actually on Ellen believe and passed
these duties on to someone else and they
got missed the third malfunction that I
found is related to haight documentation
in the oncology clinic so for most of
the oncologic medications they're dose
based on body surface areas or
accurate I documentation to do the
medication safely so the folks in the
oncology clinic asked if they could have
an alert created to be presented to the
providers to make sure that if the
patient did not have an active
documented height within the last maybe
five or six months that one was taken in
documented so they get appropriate dose
of medication so this will look again
time series months on the x-axis number
of alert firearms on the Y when it came
on was firing quite a lot for 600 600
times a month and then basically dropped
down to zero and the absence of dots
implies that it's zero but what actually
happened was the way that the patients
in this case were identified was through
throughout the department level so there
was a specific department these patients
were seeing the departments within the
electronic health record as most systems
use them they're not really virtual
representations of the physical world
there's sort of more entities that
helped push billing and scheduling
processes so they're often getting
turned on and off quite frequently this
department just got retired this type of
change comes across in a change notice
that happens you know when an analyst is
doing work and they think what they're
doing might affect someone outside their
immediate spirit so it goes into this
epic change notice that oh it just uses
but it's then left to the Alice on the
other end receiving it to sort of open
it up look at it think that it involves
them and it isn't always doesn't always
get through the last malfunction that i
have is related to coronary artery
disease and medication used so Cory our
disease is a ubiquitous chronic
condition there's a number of different
medications specifically the
antiplatelet medications which have been
shown to reduce mortality and morbidity
so when alert was created ohsu to
essentially look and see if patients had
coronary arteries but did not have the
appropriate medications ordered in a in
an outpatient say the provider would be
showing miss alert this alert was
changed and additional medications were
actually added so that it would be
suppressed or not not fire but the way
that it was done actually an error
happened
and the alert started firing much more
frequently until it was discovered I
want to show an unclassified anomaly
just to sort of make that clear so we
just went through the four malfunctions
that I found so those were alerts that
were not functioning of designer
intended then classify for ones that I
visualized or through statistical
process control determined to be
anomalies the firing pattern didn't
conform to sort of historical or
expected tatters but the validation
process was not able to classify it so
this is an alert related to
second-generation antipsychotics of
second-generation antipsychotic sir I
mean you bik witness lee use medication
for a number of mental health conditions
both fda approved and all an off-label
they have a number of side effects most
notably some of their metabolic
dysregulation they can cause elevated
cholesterol level so they require some
level of lab monitoring so the
psychiatry department asked for an alert
that would basically go through and look
to see if patients who are on it
second-generation antipsychotics
paddocks had appropriate landline so x
here's again x axis is months y axis is
the number of alert firings so this when
you start off about 60 to 100 times a
month and then basically drop down to
this lower straight state level so would
be going through this and talking with
the CDF's analysts and talking with the
pharmacy folks the lab folks the
psychiatry folks of psychiatry analysts
weren't really able to figure out why
this had dropped down to the level it
did and at a certain point i knowi to
some degree you have to sort of taking
my toe we're honest but at a certain
point there's really diminishing returns
with being able to actually determine
why this happened and we'll talk about
that a little more and then i want to do
i do want to give one example of a false
positive so this is something that it's
an anomaly but actually is expected or
something that we went digging through
and validating actually makes sense that
the firing pattern looks like so this is
related to fumble fall administration's
of propofol is a sedative it's the
medication that actually led to Michael
Jackson's demise and there is a been a
lot of shortages of the medication so
when is a shortage what happened if you
create an alert that said there's a
shortage of propofol here some
additional medications you might use for
furnace similar purposes so what
actually happened was so this alert when
you look at it it's going about 120 160
times a month and then there's these
gaping holes in it it turns out what
actually happens is the way the pharmacy
it does this it does the maintenance
related to the medication record they
similar to be knocks apparent they
create a fake medication record so
during times of propofol shortages when
I go in and I look at propofol the
medication record that I selected
actually just kind of a dummy medication
record that then bounces out to the
solar so when the alert when the
shortage is gone they pull that record
but they leave the alert in place so
unless you knew that you would
necessarily know that there's no
propofol shortage right now but that's
basically what those gaps are there's no
propofol shortage so when looking at the
performance of the SPC anomaly detection
so the SVC anomaly detection was able to
be applied to 150 for this of the 226
CES rules it found 18 out of the 19
nominees that I detected by
visualization two of the rules so if you
remember there was 21 visual anomalies
two of those CD s rules were not
amenable to statistical process control
attachment and the sensitivity of it was
ninety-five percent positive predictive
value is about twenty nine percent in
the F measure was 44 so I want to add um
just a couple of quick notes about a
couple of other things that I found it
sure wasn't looking for but I thought
were worth highlighting so the alert
that I mentioned before related to
second-generation antipsychotics and lab
monitoring i mentioned how it basically
stopped working the psychiatry folks
didn't know anything about it
interestingly enough and actually
talking to them they actually were I had
about three or four months of effort
into basically rebuild the entire same
alert but they've really had no
knowledge that that previously even
existed or a die or anything and they
were basically trying to recreate the
wheel with that which is kind of a
little bit of wasted effort a similar
situation with regard to HMO patients so
a certain group of HMO patients need to
be admitted to a special clinical
service so when they get admitted as an
alert
goes in place to make sure they get to
the right clinical service what the
older alert that we've had since 2010
was working fine went off about you know
60 to 80 times a month for two years and
then just died in trying to validate
that I wasn't able to classify that so
that when is it unclassified anomaly but
in doing the validation process actually
uncovered that someone had recreated the
same alert six months ago those speaking
with those people they didn't really
know anything about the old alert and
then this may or may not be interesting
but the reason the new alerts working is
identifying the profile is identified
with patients as being members of the
HMO by looking at who their primary care
doc is and then seeing if they're on a
master list of employees of the HMO
where is the other old alert that
doesn't seem to be working is looking to
see who the patient's ensure it and pear
is and that's sort of what a disconnect
is but anyway in both cases sort of
duplicated it and no one really had any
knowledge that those old alerts that
died for some reason people just said oh
we need this thing it realized they had
it before maybe um so to discuss some of
the findings in total we found four CD s
malfunctions and I unclassified
anomalies in a total of eighty three
hundred alert months so I would classify
all of the errors or malfunctions that I
found this really knowledge management
error so one resolute related to
medication code maintenance that was the
anoxic perrin one the one related to
influenza was about the CD s alert just
not being activated there was an
internal code change for the oncology I
documentation one women department was
retired and then direct editing of the
alert logic related to the coronary
artery disease one in comparison to the
work that Adam did Adam found but you
know I think there's two pathways that
are similar between between his work and
mine which is the lab coat change I
would sort of make that that's pretty
synonymous with I think the department
change and direct little editing in
their work they had the third party
content that caused a malfunction and
then also global software but I didn't
really see that so I think you know the
anomaly or the
functions that I found there's really no
reason to think they wouldn't be in any
implementation of commercial systems
that are out there because they're not
necessarily related specifically to the
commercial system we have it's really
about the knowledge management an
implementation of clinical decision
support the nine unclassified I think in
in a lot of ways represent you know a
lot more concerned with the ones that I
know what they are and I know what the
pathways are we can talk about ways to
sort of prevent those and detect those
but the the unclassified ones it
wouldn't surprise me if there's a number
of different pathways underlying that
which may be some of why it's harder to
validate it but i think it's it's a
super important group to to look further
into and i think also it's likely you
know one of the limitations will talk
about it a little bit more but is that
this is not retrospectively so when I
would go to people and I would say hey
do you remember March 12 2011 maybe
something happy that was interesting
probably not you know and so I you know
I think of it sick industry you're
looking for a needle in a haystack that
he may be dropped it three or four years
ago and you're not sure you know which
haystack you dropped it in but I think
if you're doing this prospective a you
can sort of you know sort of call back
to whoever's involved and say hey
yesterday this alert just stopped
functioning I think it'd be much easier
for people to be able to recall what
happened so when talking about you know
these findings what are the ways in
which I sort of approach it sort of adds
both prevention and detection so what
are the ways in which we can prevent
this it's easy to sort of throw up and
say okay we're going to say you know you
just every time you change the system it
needs to be tested and and that you know
isn't really feasible I mean the amount
of changes that are going on in the
system are astronomical I think you know
changes directly to the alert logic yes
that stuff needs to be tested but I
think changes within the system are a
little bit more complicated I think the
you know one of the pieces is having a
system that actually looks at some of
the attributes so the way that it works
is you know if I'm an analyst and I make
a change in the system and I think it
affects that people I said it throughout
through this basically like kind of
blast email system you know but it's
really complicated actually try to look
through the whole build and find out
where is it that hematocrit is being
used okay if I'm going to change
hematocrit if the lab
Luhrmann retire this department I it's
probably better to do that almost one
time or be able to map that to the
system but it's it's pretty awkward to
do as it currently stands and i think
but i think you know if you're able to
sort of create some system that is able
to sort of automated or track all those
attributes do there i think that would
be much help more helpful our knowledge
management tools that we use in CES
aren't really tied into the activity of
the alerts themselves so we have we're
using some microsoft sharepoint products
which basically allow us to sort of
communicate and keep track of tasks and
lists and things but they don't actually
tie into what's actually going on so
when it's influenza season and there's
15 alerts that need to be sort of
updated and turned on that's just kind
of you know that's kind of us almost has
to do list but when it doesn't happen we
don't necessarily have a way of sort of
spotting that and then another piece I
think that's important is the versioning
so we have the way the system is you can
basically just overwrite everything when
you create when you create a new record
you can just keep the same record just
keep overriding which is what a lot most
of the institutions are doing for CES
you can actually use versioning on that
and track that out and that would
definitely be something to look into and
then I think also as far as prevention
there's also other things that we need
to consider when we sort of discover
what those other pathways are from the
unclassified group as far as detection
of the statistical process control
method was able to be applied to about
seventy percent of the cohort I think a
lot of that limit the limitation of that
was sort of twofold one there's a whole
host of alerts that you know aren't
doing all that much meaning they're not
firing that frequently and therefore it
doesn't you know if you have something
that's firing once a week and then a
couple times the next week you can't
really apply statistical process control
to it and then also you're sort of
limited when you're doing it
retrospectively so if I do it
retrospectively I have to set an
aggregate line for the whole group
because I don't necessarily know when an
intervention is actually coming in that
would affect it but if you're doing it
prospective li you can continue to you
can continuously sort of reset your your
control line when when something changes
that you're aware of so I think you know
if you're able to run this perspective
and be able to apply this statistical
process control methods much more
broadly and then probably just use
visualization as a supplement to those
that
it's not amenable to so some of the
strengths and limitations so this work
was done in the commercial system which
is really the the standard that
everybody else is using everything I did
and used in this study is all
commercially available tools so anyone
should be able to pretty easily
replicate the work one of the
limitations as I mentioned before I use
control charts meaning it's just number
of events per time and so what that
basically assumes the underlying
denominator is not changing that's a
sort of i think valid and necessary
assumption i think it's valid because
one the underlying you know the
denominators if they're chained if they
were changing significantly would have
to be rather large event so outside of
twenty percent and the reality is if you
wanted to try to go back in and
replicate each individual group every
time it changes and try and plot those
denominators I think the reality is
you've probably introduced more error
than and then any benefit you could
likely gain another limitation as I
mentioned it sort of using aggregate
control lines and which is just sort of
the reality if you're doing this
retrospectively so I had to take 2010
through 2015 and just have a single
average line it wasn't able to reset the
control limits for the statistical
process control because i didn't really
know when something was going to happen
and then the underlying characteristics
describing statistical process control
you know they really lack a gold
standard but it's i think it was a fair
assessment to sort of take it and
compared to the visualization method and
as for future work i think implementing
this you know trying to implement this
prospective Lee would would go a long
way to helping us with our clinical
decision support work and then exploring
methods for sort of tracking the
attribute changes automatically rather
than having a sort of blast notification
system so just to revisit what I hope
were the research objectives which maybe
I achieved so one was to determine
whether there were clinical decision
support malfunctioning is occurring in
the commercial EHR I did find there were
four confirmed ones and nine
unclassified ones and then the pathways
we describe those who went to those in
excruciating detail and then we talked I
talked about the methods of detection
and prevention so just in conclusion
total 226 alerts 8300 alert months for
confirmed malfunctions 9 unclassified
anomalies which make me nervous all in
all all the malfunctions or knowledge
related and statistical process control
augmented with visualization is a
promising that could fit method for CD s
malfunction detection so I want to thank
Dave who's my committee chair doctors
Tom dr. yackel and Gorman Adam Wright
who has been very helpful with the work
I've done Denise and L Diana Pennington
and Neela do who all been very helpful
on some of the validation stuff and then
obviously want to thank dr. Hirsch for
the opportunity to be here in total in
the training grant and Virginia who's
been a very very helpful resource and
friend thank you very much Virginia
alfredo for always being funny Rory sits
next to me which is probably bad for her
because I always have lots of questions
are hey take a look at this but I always
appreciated her she's always willing to
lend an ear and all the fellows and
staff so thank you everybody very much
Dion hunter can end up first go ahead
okay how are you gonna explain to so I
think the new reality is it probably the
way that the health care payments are
changing it's not really anything you
need to explain to anyone except
yourself so I think most of the
organization's you know as you move away
from fee-for-service and things are more
focused on value the need to be able to
sort have a better handle on what your
sort of quality improvement initiatives
and what your clinical decision support
is that stuff's really going to inform
your essentially you know your your
reimbursements going into the future so
if but you can try and explain it to me
if you want
yeah no that's you though you know yes
I'm sorry well I see there's a question
question is how do we proceed future
work without a gold standard that I
guess my question is going to be your
your numbers are relatively small so
your system seems to have a more
sensitive and specific event which is
this is a future actually when your
office mate Rory's all these genomic
clinical decision support increases
methods be scalable yes I think you know
this the statistical process control i
think is scalable right i mean there's
no reason you couldn't automate all of
that i think that you know having to do
visual reviews on it i mean i think the
reality is the clinical decision support
it's a very resource intensive process
and even if you're not spending a lot of
time just looking at how well it
actually performing the reality is you
need to actually find out if it did what
you wanted which is even even sort of
further along and is that you know
having the content be valid so I think
the to sort of answer your question I
think the statistical process control is
and i think it probably can be applied
to most of this cohort I think alerts
that aren't happening that much and they
never happen that much I mean I don't
think you need to you can sort of
monitor those in the sort of you know
kind of sort of maybe just have some a
different threshold limit you're not
going to use to the co-prosperity you
know this alert never fires one in ten
times in a day or a week and so I think
you know most of this could be handled
by statistical process control what
about a gold standard also lack of a
gold standard um it's that's a tough one
that I don't necessarily have a great
answer to I think the reality is for
this it's you can't you know the
resources just don't allow you to
validate the whole cohort
but i think you know as people spend
more time actually looking at the CD s I
think figuring out what pathways and
then being able to find out you know
additional pathways that maybe this
method just doesn't pick up at all right
there may be some pathways worth it for
whatever reason the amount of alert
firing is exactly the same and that
doesn't change so I don't be yeah I just
have a comment Steve a really nice job
you've I think succeeded in helping us
in the first step of change management
the first step is to admit you have a
problem and until you quantify the
problem around clinical decision support
in this way people think it's probably
functioning properly what you've
demonstrated is a way for us to identify
how often it's not functioning properly
which I think the people that have been
working in this area for a while know
that it's broken all the time or maybe
more often than anybody wishes maybe all
the time is a bit bit too far but uh you
know so I so I don't know maybe Ross
couple well this will be his next area
that he'll pick up on but so I think
you've just started to focus attention
on an area that needs a lot more work to
Bill's point or me so many unanswered
questions about this how do you set it
up the properly study these you know we
don't know where are the best
opportunities to try to reduce the
errors in the future we're not really
sure the first step is admitting that
you have a problem and I think these
methods start to move us down the path
of being able to quantify how often
clinical decision support is in fact not
doing what you think it's doing well so
um got a sort of following on heroin he
analyzed the Three Mile Island actually
that came up with a theory called normal
accidents he said when systems are so
complex that you really can't understand
them
and things are tightly coupled then
accidents are going to happen inevitably
and no two accidents will be the same so
I'm really nervous about nine
unclassified CD s anomalies that we
don't even we can't figure out what they
were um do you think the aim Tom invest
his resources in prevention trying to
improve processes so that CBS anomalies
don't happen or detection so that he can
capture them trouble can you just take
whatever pile of money he hasn't split
in half oh so equal so the pile is small
but yeah but either way yeah I mean is
your question which where do I think
there's many more the money is in terms
of trying to alleviate my fears if you
if you ask me what I won't want to focus
most of my effort on I'd actually want
to focus more of it on prevention
because I think the reality is I think a
good portion of what you're seeing here
is the fact that we birth these alerts
you know the egg cracks open they get
pushed out of the nest and that's it you
know we let them fly and and no there's
not a lot of effort being done to go
back and look at them I think a lot of
these you would find if you were trying
to do prevention on them right so you
would come across these normal if you
just said okay we have a process this
alert it's going to be revisited in six
months time we're going to check to see
if it's still guideline compliant we're
going to see how often people are
overriding it we're going to see how
often it's firing and I you know I I
know that sort of its prevention with a
lot of sort of detection baked into it
but I think that you know having a
tighter knowledge management process
around you know I think we're good at
taking requests rollers creating the
alerts testing them but I think then you
know following that life cycle back up
this is where the nose back to the nest
for a checkup so
okay thank you um I was wondering about
that issue yeah so does i understand it
yes but sort of complementary to the
whole issue any name cuz other people
yeah so I mean overall wrong right right
so the overriding I mean it sort of ism
is it kind of background for what I'm
looking at so I didn't necessarily look
at it um yeah I mean I think yeah no I
think so I mean I think at least in my
mind you know it's sort of like you know
if you're going to put CD s out there
you are obligated to make sure that it
functions properly a part of that
functioning properly is making sure that
it's actually useful